what's up sweet tits uh you gotta check
out my fall dates all on sale now at
salvolcanocomedy.com
we got uh toronto we have hamilton
canada ontario there richmond virginia
hershey pennsylvania second show added
knoxville uh atlanta second show added
birmingham louisville evansville
jacksonville tampa orlando sacramento
san jose santa rosa all on sale right
now savilecanoecomedy.com merch is up
there too uh yeah that's my next dates
and that's going to be it for a little
while so make sure you get out there
thanks guys
all right and then this head hey folks
joe derosa here from the taste buds
podcast i got dates i got dates i got
dates go to joederosainfo.com
to check them out you can also buy your
tickets there get all the show info you
need
first up atlantic city new jersey then i
will be heading off to san diego
california i am also hitting somerville
in massachusetts after that north
carolina
and some other stuff
joederosainfo.com new dates are being
added all the time and if you're in new
york city come to joey roses if you're
not in new york city and you want to
make a trip come to joey rose's joey
roses nyc joeyrosesnyc.com for all the
info on the spot that serves both
alcohol and sandwiches at amazing prices
opening tuesday through sunday at 12 p.m
every day
taste joeyrosesnyc.com they coming to
the mic talking about the food they hate
talking about the food they like two
fools gonna fight but only one food can
be right taste got something in your
hair
what's that i don't know it's like
fuzz or something
it's a big piece where is it toward the
front left
is it off now go up a little higher
something right there
oh my god i'm kidding
[Laughter]
you sold it you sold it i'm keeping it
oh yeah
yeah that's the whole intro
you got to switch the intro sometimes
that's the intro this week what did you
yeah i was like what could that have
been
what was i
yeah i was pretending it was a some kind
of spider or something
i walked into my house yesterday from
outside
and literally a lantern fly was on my
neck a wet fly a lanternfly those
invasive things that are everywhere now
they come by like the millions dude
they're everywhere they hatch and they
come like they started coming out last
summer they came from china they
destroyed trees they're everywhere dude
you don't see them they're everywhere
like i don't live near a single tree oh
those are that's beautiful though they
are disgusting and i want them all dead
and i'll do everything beautiful that it
is that's not beautiful actually
scientists made an announcement please
kill them if you're in new york or kill
these if you see them
yeah because they're just gonna
expand it's beautiful i've killed last
year i killed a couple hundred
this year i i they're that's colorful
though 15 there's a red wing underneath
the rest i found that on my neck i hit
it off it fell on the floor in my house
i was like ah
i think it's very pretty look
it's very pretty looking
good why don't you marry it
oh boy
what an attitude
oh sorry it's disgusting are these
things destroying your uh deck they they
huddle up they do they destroy
everything
i've been on your deck it's made of
concrete what are they gonna do there's
a deck above the concrete oh god forbid
they eat what god forbid is this do you
have the audacity with everything going
on in the world to complain about your
top deck no you're talking listen to me
listen to me it's not even your deck
you're not talking you're not just
kidding
this is something that we're all going
through together except for you you're
not understanding that these things come
by the thousands to people's yards
thousands and they just they literally
cover a tree and they just did to kill
the tree maybe it's a message
that it's time for us to move on
do you ever think that us maybe we're
the maybe we're the pests and a bigger
species is coming in now i need this
from you right now i don't need this
from you right now you don't need this
you're gonna get it because it's a
battle today new york nice time's over
july 2020 was when they got here last
year july 21 is when they asked me and
now they're back and it's it's it's
clockwork it is not considered a
widespread threat to our city's forest
it says it right there
they infest trees though
while it can infest trees it is not
considered a widespread threat to our
city's forests i'm telling you right now
in this neighborhood alone they've cut
down like six trees because once they
get into them there's no way to get rid
of them seeing the neighborhood you live
in
do you think this is a visually nice
neighborhood to look at what does that
have to do
these these bugs are making an
improvement in the neighborhood
i'm telling you joe they're they're
they're not good
what trees
i've been coming here for two years i've
seen a pile of rocks
some rotted wood i could talk to you
from the ground i could talk to you
about what trees uh offline offline yeah
i don't want to describe [ __ ] all right
what fun is that to the me telling you
which tree do you think somebody's gonna
figure out where you live because you
describe a tree saying though like
you're gonna you want me to explain what
tree to you is how's that good
podcasting uh
the
the your immediate surroundings are very
nice
great i'm just telling you my god that
even if i immediately i don't know my
immediate surroundings the trees are
getting attacked by these things well
okay but outside of the immediate
dear god
i mean you live
in the lower east side yeah the last
time i went to your house someone threw
their [ __ ] at me after they took it
but that's supposed to happen
it's not supposed to happen here
i love that it happens everywhere he's
siding with the invasive species yeah
yeah yeah i mean you're the only person
that he pulls up an invasive species
that is multiplying over the last few
years that scientists are urging us to
kill that have been diverted we're an
invasive species look at what we've done
to the planet look at the trees we've
killed why they are they do they hire
you as their council why are you
defending them oh i'm sorry that the
peach tree won't be fruitful enough for
mr sao volcano anymore because somebody
else wants to take a bite well the
birthday the birthday episodes are over
folks
let's get right into it let's get right
into it let's do it you ready yeah
it's time to get salty it's time to get
salty it's time to get salty your
neighborhood
looks like [ __ ]
i mean i feel like i just i can just say
i know you are but what am i
all right ready your turn
it's not gonna get salty it's time to
get salty it's time to get salty you
didn't need to drive to find out who you
were all you had to do was save 25 grand
and look
[Laughter]
you could have gave me 10 bucks i could
have told you who you are
i can't argue it i can't argue it
uh here we go it's mcdonald's versus
pizza of course you know what team i'm
on
uh this is part three the final chapter
of the birthday extravaganza
uh and it's time for the battle it was a
lot of niceties leading up to this
now you saw some anger
from me when sal kept singing
you saw a little bit of tension but for
for all intents and purposes they were
pretty friendly episodes yeah i also
yelled at an audience in san francisco
that had a lot of taste buddies at it oh
really they're being too tight and i go
cut the [ __ ] guys i'm not doing this for
45 minutes loosen the [ __ ] up let's go
it's not going to get any brighter
let's go yeah they started laughing and
then afterwards or at the toward the end
i go how many you were podcast fans and
a decent amount of people clapped and i
was like well there you go
you got to freak out in real life now
you know it's not a show
there's something wrong with me
uh but anyway
uh here we go as we sit here i love
pizza hut
i love it i love pizza i miss sit down
we're gonna do ba tt le buds or oh [ __ ]
i forgot all right do tsc buds in the
beginning just so you know something now
i know all right we'll do the battle
buds ready
here we go b-a-t-t-l-e
bunch
all right
uh
i love pizza hut i love pizza i love
pizza on my road trip
three times
i stopped at brick and mortar pizza huts
because i had not seen one in so long i
love it
and you know a pizza hut
when you see a pizza yes because the
pizza hut
built their own buildings yes and had
their own aesthetic
for an exterior same as taco bell which
not a lot of people do same as taco bell
you could tell a revamped taco bell and
a revamped pizza every time
and i was so excited
see these are the new ones but those red
roof no no that one there with the red
roof
that's classic pizza
i saw three of those while i was driving
the classic traditional pizza i
coincidentally
it was around time to eat when i saw all
three
i went into all three
and immediately walked out they are just
shells housing a takeout pizza place now
there's no more table service there is
nothing there's no more you can see that
that building like that like on the left
there you couldn't get there was no
waiter you walk in the salad bar
pushed off and empty to the side empty
yeah it was like they just they're not
functioning i'm not necessarily arguing
like the two you went into
no i went into three sure in three
different areas i'm i'm arguing them
their whole career i'm just well i'm
getting to a point okay please i walked
in excited to relive this childhood
thing and immediately walked out because
what they are now is just
it's just basically like any fast food
place where it's like you can order at
the counter and if you want to sit here
you can
and if you don't then don't but what was
yeah but but
that's what it is right now but you went
in there for a reason what was the
reason you went in for because that's a
good pizza right but you went in because
you wanted to i love pizza but i also
wanted to experience i'm getting to the
point i wanted to experience the pizza i
experienced as a kid now i did have
pizza hut once on this trip and it was
with my buddy jim when i was in atlanta
and it was awesome and it was fun but
you did have pizza and you went for
three other stops for pizza no no before
i saw him i went into these three hoping
to relive this thing this is the point
i'm getting at i still think pizza is
great but i think when they stopped with
the sit-down restaurants they that's
when they started to dip there's a
there's a there's a quality dip that
happened with pizza there's something
different i don't know what it is it's
still good i still enjoy it but there is
something different that happened
and
excuse me it came in the
it comes in the effort depart oh look at
that it started in kansas it's it's
let's get some info let's get something
there's something in the effort
department where quality dropped
and i don't know quite what i can't
speak to that right now look at that old
pizza they were doing that roof from
1968. in 1958 two brothers borrowed 600
beans
from their mom to open a pizza place in
wichita kansas they named it pizza magic
beans because their sign only had room
for eight letters
wow they started pizza hut two brothers
from kansas for six hundred
dollars
pizza had his american multinational
restaurant chain an international
franchise founded in 58 by dan and frank
carney they serve their signature pan
pizza and other dishes including pasta
breadsticks and desserts
uh let's see uh the chain has 18
381 restaurants worldwide as of last
year making it the world's largest pizza
chain
pizza hut was founded okay we got that
is it a franchise or just a chain look
at this one early employee was future
pro football hall of fame coach bill
parcells giants coach who had worked for
the company while a college student and
football player at wichita state
university parcells was considering a
franchise for a career as well as law
school but instead chose to enter
coaching
all right
my brothers began franchising in 59 the
iconic pizza hut building style was
designed in 63 by a chicago architect
named george liddstrom lindstrom
and was implemented by 16. look at this
pepsico acquired taco bell kfc and pizza
hut
kfc is another place where you the build
it has its own style building
yeah that's what i'm saying yeah oh so
they know what they're doing there yeah
they're brand all the way is that the
building or the first pizza hut
look at that it looks like a small small
little bungalow home oh that's oh i
thought it was the one they showed in
the other so did i
but it makes this makes more sense six
hundred dollars yeah which also
which also and this is a compliment to
pizza which it makes sense that it
started in wichita kansas
it's got its own thing it's got its own
vibe this is what i will always love
about pizza hut
but it's also what i love about
mcdonald's
you cannot recreate pizza hut you cannot
recreate mcdonald's period you can't
make it at home you could never in a
million years make something at home
that tastes like pizza you want to just
i'm going to read a little bit more
about them but just to talk to this
because we had mcdonald's for your
birthday
and you talked about a drop in quality
of a pizza hut
you tell me that tell me that this was
not a subpar mcdonald's experience
it was good it was just nuggets were a
little off to fry everything was cold
when we ate it though yeah but those
fries were off like what was it i think
it was a dip in koala i thought they
were just cold i still mcdonald's fries
to me when they're when they're fresh
you can't i've never defended mcdonald's
fries cold they don't last well
but when they're ready to go they are
the best things on planet earth i did
notice nobody tried the apple pie
oh i didn't even see it
i'll eat it
i'll eat it while pat well sal reeves
throw it in the microwave now
what are we doing at this point
[Laughter]
i don't know in 2017 pizza was listed by
the uk based company richie topia as the
number 24 in a list of 200 most
influential brands in the world
june 25th and 27 2019 reported that
pizza is bringing back their logo and
red roof design that was used from 1976
to 1999.
oh it's check this out in 2019 announced
its intention pizza to close 500
of its 7 500 dining restaurants in the
united states by the middle of 21. so
that's you caught one of those
that's unbelievable
even ice cold that's still delicious
bite the other end that i didn't bite
oh there's two
here have your own
pizza is split into several different
restaurant formats the original family
style dine in location storefront
delivery and carryout location now
here's the thing i didn't think they did
delivery
growing up they didn't do delivery and
that was like a boss ass move to be a
pizza place that was like nah i'm not
going to deliver
i mean you could if you deliver i mean
it's it's a built-in thing like people
expect delivery that's a whole nother
revenue stream
that they were like we don't even need
that
but
when i was a kid
when i was a kid
delivery was a new thing i lived in the
suburbs
delivery hit the cities first
as a suburb kid delivery was like
really never in a million years would
i've expected people people chinese
no dude when dominoes opened and they
delivered it was like what
yeah i i always remember delivery when i
was little no you lived in the city
i was in staten island
but still it's gonna take it didn't you
live in a suburb of philadelphia
no
yes technically but no
it wasn't like i lived in the city
suburb in the sub atlanta summer it's
considered a summer for philly but it's
a summer outside of philadelphia okay
that's not that's nice the um
no delivery was a huge thing some of the
pizza places started to
i'm going to read this a second some of
the pizza places started to but this
would happen all the time you'd call for
delivery
and they go sorry our delivery guy is
only here at these times and they had
one guy
and that was it it wasn't until i was in
my teens that delivery was really
really a normal thing i've been going to
a pizzeria when we were younger they all
looked the same
they had a couple of a couple of tables
in the front like booths kind of things
and the these prices were all on those
little like
little they like spelled them out with
the little plastic letters that they
pushed into like the yeah
the board and it was like you go in you
get a fountain soda and a slice for like
a dollar yeah and then you then you've
got some quarters and there's usually a
video game in there you play little
video games our pizza hut had video
games in it
and so did our 7-eleven
our pizza hut is where i was introduced
to the video game 1942
okay playing game
uh and uh 7-eleven is where i was
introduced to
a game that changed my life double
dragon
at the pizza no that was at the 7-eleven
but i remember kids would line up to
play double you know the song i'm at the
pizza and i'm at the taco bell right no
that's racist we visited this on the uh
on the other one yeah
i'm at the pizza hut i'm at the taco
bell i'm at the combination pizza hut
and taco bell no no joe hated it if i
remember oh i did yeah okay that sounds
about right you did here uh
next right next to the staten island
pizza hut was a department store store
called masters when i was younger and in
the foyer in the vestibule going in they
had tecmo bowl
i never played the arcade version i only
played the home version oh man we
couldn't wait to go there to play tech
mobile but let's just get let's get back
to the basics of what we're here to do
today
you can't
in your right mind
think
as good as pizza hut is and man it is
good i love pizza
in your right mind think it can hold
stand a chance
against the champion look at this look
at what is look at the majesty of what
is before did you bite that pie yet but
that's good the first recorded food
delivery was believed to be taking place
in naples italy in 1889. okay look at me
i do think it is i'll tell you why but
if we're gonna boil it down first of all
pizza hut is the best chain pizza that
going i agree i don't think there's a
better chain pizza place than pizza hut
i agree people will get furious people
will scream dominoes people will scream
paw patrol you want pizza hut is what i
think is the best pizza place now pizza
is at the top pizza is the big dog right
and they're the big dog of the chain
pizzas which is a big thing okay
pear i wear
a love pair i wear why
cause i wear eyewear and i like what
pear does with eyewear uh look life is
full of little opportunities to express
yourself in a moment right and keep your
creativity flowing throughout the day
as somebody that wears glasses i think
that uh your eyeglasses are a big part
of that uh your style evolves and it's
your glasses are part of that if you're
if you wear them they're part of your
look they're part of your style they're
part of your expression okay and because
of the typical approach to eyewear from
the eyewear industry a lot of the times
you're very limited with those options
you know frames cost a certain amount of
money uh it's hard to buy multiple
frames because of what they cost and
even if you do buy multiple frames
you're kind of locked in to what those
frames look like
that's where pair eyewear comes in to
change the game one pair endless
possibilities glasses do not have to be
boring
go check out pair i'm telling you go
check out what they do okay
it's really really really cool
i got i can do this part right here so
first of all on the website you're gonna
do the virtual try-on okay which lets
you sample their wide variety of frames
and shapes and all that stuff right from
your computer which i love
i don't know what it is about going into
an optical store i don't like doing it i
love that you can do this virtually
they got all kinds of lenses all right
blue light they got sunglasses they're
readers light responsive lenses
any kind of lens you want
all right but here's the coolest part
there are base frames and then tops
which you can choose so you get a base
frame and then you have these tops that
you can put onto the base frame and you
can switch it all it's just so cool it's
just so cool maybe you're into retro
maybe you're into classic maybe you're
into like a neon maybe you're into neon
this morning but retro later doesn't
matter
pear is letting you do you you choose
from a range of iconic base shapes that
start at just 60 that's including the
prescription
and then you can choose from hundreds of
magnetic matching tops that make it easy
to switch up your look
boom
on the fly whenever you feel like it
instantaneously with pair you get a
great pair of glasses at a great play
price that are fun and that's it all
right so do this check it out over 200
million by the way over 200 million
children worldwide need glasses and
can't get them all right
so when you buy pair you're helping some
of those kids because for every pair of
glasses you buy pear provides glasses to
a child in need that's pretty awesome so
go to pear eyewear dot com slash taste
buds for 15 off your purchase that's 15
off at p a i r
iwear.com tastebuds
folks
let's talk money for a second from
cringing at the pump to getting
an eye-popping check at your favorite
restaurant i've been there inflation is
hitting us all
where it hurts and it really hurts
that's why i like
upside okay upside is an incredible app
for anyone who buys gas groceries or
dines out with every purchase you're
earning cash back thanks to upside i'm i
use it it works it's really cool okay
all you have to do is download the
upside app and it's free
you can get at the app store the google
play store or whatever
and use promo code taste buds you're
gonna get five dollars or more cash back
on your first purchase of ten dollars or
more all right
here's what happens you go out you pay
for things with your card as you would
and now when you do it with upside
you're getting money back
that's that's it it's that simple okay
and unlike credit card rewards or
loyalty programs you can earn three
times more in cash back with upside it's
really really great you can cash out any
time at your bank account pay you can
cash out at any time to your bank
account paypal or an e-gift card for
amazon or or other brands upside users
are earning more than a million dollars
every week that's probably why they have
a 4.8 star rating right now on the app
store so so again again
you want to use this it's great i use it
it's awesome download the free upside
app and use promo code taste buds
you're going to get five dollars or more
cash back on your first purchase of ten
dollars or more that's five dollars or
more cash back on your first purchase of
ten dollars or more using promo code
taste buds uh pizza
is the king of all foods i still think
that
the last episode is gonna be pizza
versus everything i really do
and i i feel that they're the best pizza
is the best of the pizza chains so i
don't think you should look at pizza hut
lightly as an opponent wait a minute you
think pizza is the king of all foods
yeah
i don't think i don't think anything
will beat pizza hut in a battle a pizza
in a battle i don't think anything
name the thing that's going to be pizza
in a battle
well a fan suggested pizza versus
chocolate i think shock chocolate's got
a hell of a shot
that's probably one of the few things
that might compete and i would agree
that universally pizza is
is
the well the most universal food
the most accessible food the most fun
food all these things
if you came to me though and said you
could have one food for the rest of your
life i never in a million years would
you say pizza
i would take burgers over it
oh you're insane i would take tacos a
thousand times overall i would take
fried chicken over you're in the
minority there i could people could eat
pizza nearly every day people can't eat
burgers every day fried chicken every
day i can't eat pizza every day really i
think i think more people eat i think
pizza out of everything you name i think
pizza is the thing that's eaten most
frequently
by the general person
[Music]
you said people eating tacos
that are not like i see women
i see way more people i know
in this city
like the states like i'm not really
saying like obviously like in mexico
there might be mexican fair eating more
than traditional pizza but i just mean
three-pointer
i see way i know way more people that
frequent tacos than i know eat frequent
pizza most people love p pizza but they
don't eat it very often because of how
unhealthy it is but they will go well
i'll get a corn tortilla soft taco with
no cheese and uh you talk about pizza
because if you pull up pizza it's menu
it blows mcdonald's bowls you're insane
how am i you're insane all right let's
go let's go to the tape bud
first of all the pan pizza is synonymous
with pizza hut
it's a golden crispy crust it's
delicious and it stops staying hot and
it's stuck there
that's all they need by the way
what about the crust
i wouldn't cross this couch for a piece
of stuffed crust pizza that's a lie no
it's not i mean look at what you're
eating how dare you say you wouldn't
cross the couch for a pizza i don't like
stuffed crushed peas if i had a piping
hot stuffed crust pizza in my hand you
wouldn't come from here to there i don't
like to get a slice it's too much it's
obnoxious
breadsticks
bread salad balls oh you mean you mean
the worst part of the pizza without any
of the goodies about this how about this
let me show you guys
let me ask you a question one of my
favorite things in the world
when i went to pizza hut that resonated
with me i'm listening
i i attached two pizzas hit me with it
is
the cups
wait a minute stop stop hold on stick on
one thing here i am
i have the cups of joey roses that's
what i'm getting at boy that's what i'm
getting but that's not the menu because
no matter you actually took from we
serve a food at joey rose's and i think
it's superior to pizza hoagies are
superior to pizza you too
you you serve your your drinks in pizza
hut cups at your bar yes or no the red
plastic frosted cups inspired by pizza
yes all right i'm just making some
points here yeah but you get back to the
menu being better there you go
tell me why i pulled out the main page
uh pimp there's no main pages wherever
you saw you were scrolling and there was
you got pizza no there was a all right
there was a picture before of like like
like yeah it was their pasta go to the
homepage go to home page
yeah right there look at that look at
that that right there that picture looks
better than everything on mcdonald's
menu you've got two of the same pizza
deep which is crust crunchy golden brown
pepperoni pizza i'm not saying the pizza
isn't great but that picture is two pan
pizzas then you have breadsticks which
are fine they're good but it's the crust
with some cheese sprinkled on it so it's
redundant to the thing you're already
eating and then those wings i guarantee
you are disgusting
you think those wings look good
i'm really defending the pizza no no no
no no
you shot your big mouth off that their
menu was better joe i bet you those
wings are better than the mcnugget
you're
insane
stop it oh you got to stop it joe stop
you think defend the menu hand me the
[ __ ] hammer
hand me a big nugget no you don't get no
show the big nugget to the camera
protection don't get to eat a two-hour
cold mcnugget show the mcnugget to the
camera for texture show it that's better
than what it's better then yeah it's
better than a full wheel
when it's fresh it is fresh
is fresh the whole thing is processed oh
those are chicken breaded chicken bites
that are dipped in some kind of glaze of
some sort that is nice it's buffalo
glaze
here we go oh of some sort how about
they have seven sauces garlic parmesan
honey barbecue buffalo mild spicy garlic
buffalo medium sweet chili and buffalo
burning hot that's the sauces they also
have dry rubs lemon pepper and cajun
style okay and don't
forget
ranch blue cheese garlic honey barbecue
buffalo and marinara they have boneless
and classic bone-in they also have
pastas which i i will say that i've
never ever seen or had their pastas but
if we can go to the pastas i'll give you
a chicken alfredo uh baked italian meat
which is i guess uh so if you try to
defend
these pastas right now that are
literally look me look at me
these are literally
pastas
which
that's a
real loose usage of the words
listen to me listen to me i've never
tried the prophet just listen to me i
think just like let me finish
these are pastas cause you said their
entire menu these are pastas that they
put the same toppings they put on the
pizzas
yes they are look at this look at the
recipe for baked italian meats pasta
pepperoni it has it
and those toppings are only good when
they are fried up to a crust on top of a
pizza i mean they're picking the one
pasta they have chicken alfredo they
have veggie pasta
yeah you know the high quality veggies
they have in pizza
yeah but but how could you dance say
something like you make fun of the high
quality anything
babe what sorry what are the high
quality items on your mind look at this
look at this what are the high quality
items take me home look at this how good
does every one of these things look
right a chicken sandwich a cheeseburger
a mcnugget big mac in all of its majesty
look at that egg mcmuffin look at that
quarter pounder with cheese pimp click
on the [ __ ] chicken sandwich let's
get this i'm going to say something to
you mcdonald's has lost to wendy's
already oh because people don't know
what they're talking about
everybody is
where is the fresh ingredients that
you're talking about as you shove a
mcnugget down your gullet
i never forget yes you did
you you you were mocking pizza hut as
how you dig those vegetables are
so tell me what's fresh on your menu
here's why here's why i'm mocking pizza
mcdonald's wouldn't dare hand you
something called a vegetable whatever
yeah you could i guarantee you you could
order a veggie burger an impossible
burger at mcdonald's an impossible
burger
that's [ __ ] too
it's it's all it's all processed
you cannot you could not [ __ ] on pizza
double cheeseburger you could not [ __ ]
on pizza that's not how it looks when
you get it and everyone knows
oh that's that's a glamour shot show
that's a glamour shot piece exactly it
looks great the photos the beauty of
mcdonald's they put fake [ __ ] in your
mouth
so it can look the same
you know what what'd you say there was a
cheeseburger here let's get the [ __ ]
cheeseburger out is there anything i ate
already
no let's hold this up i'm gonna walk up
to the screen with this pull up a
picture of large fries look how
delicious that looks hold on zoom in
pimp look look at him they're soggy
white disgusting fries for three hours
joe your cheeseburger that you ate did
not look like that joe the cheese
doesn't fold over and pour it it's
overlaying each other it's a crock of
[ __ ] yeah compare the two compare the
two right now go ahead look at every fry
in there is literally standing at full
attention next to each other
[Laughter]
no it does not like that are you nuts
it looks nothing alike been sitting here
for hours now it doesn't look like that
joe come on you know the glamour shots
the pizza
the pizza photos on the pizza hut
website look way more like the actual
pizza than your fries and burgers look
like in reality on the website yes they
do
mcdonald's is
all right if i was like if i had and i
had a family right and we were out and
we were we're out for the day running
errands going to the mall going to the
bank what have you i picked the kids
we're going to eat how much kardashian
did i just walk through
[Laughter]
we all deal with sunday scaries right
guys sunday scaries are those oh [ __ ]
stressful nervous can't sleep dreadful
feelings that hit you on sunday evening
when you think about the impending doom
of work uh tomorrow or school or just
life unfortunately you can feel that
same pit in your stomach any day of the
week like myself
sunday scaries are the oh [ __ ] moments
waking up on the couch noticing you left
your credit card at the bar
and texted your ex
or dealing with five pointless zoom
calls a day and micro and a micro
managing boss again very this is hitting
very close to home
sunday scary cbd gummies were made to
defeat the crap that life throws at us
they're the perfect cbd gummies for
professionals on the grind super moms
students party animals regretful drunk
sexters and everyone in between uh look
i don't relax well guys i have a crazy
schedule it's hard to shut my brain off
and chill that's in the copy but it
might as well have been completely
written for myself i overthink i stress
myself out sunday scary's deliciously
cute vitamin boosted cbd gummies on my
must-have because they actually work and
they chill me out fast you've heard us
talk about cbd before
it works and i like sunday scary 2022 is
all about self-love and taking better
care of yourselves and myself so whether
i need to take the edge off calm my
racing mind or just sleep better or
chill sunday scary cbd gummies are the
answer we all have the right to live
scare free let me save you with my 25
discount visit sunday scarys.com and use
promo code tastebuds for your discount
that's promo code tastebuds for 25 off
at sundayscaries.com
[Music]
we're gonna we're gonna we're gonna eat
out right i'm i'm i'm i'm uh at the head
of the fight you think the parents are
gonna say like let's all go sit down
at mcdonald's for dinner or is the more
family-friendly environment hey let's go
go sit at pizza hut and get dinner you
can't sit at pizza out anymore it's my
point you you went into the three of the
500 stores out of 18 000 that don't
serve and my parents and i used to oh my
gosh
my parents and i used to always go sit
down choke on your poison
all right you want to talk sitting down
at a restaurant what does anybody say
let's have a pizza hut birthday party
for the kids mcdonald's
i'm sure that pizza had plenty of
birthday parties of a pizza party
a pizza at birthday party yeah okay well
yeah that's because
that's just their marketing directly to
children
all right how about think about any
other burger place that is selling
burgers they don't have a clown and a
playpen in the restaurant because these
people knew it right crock in them knew
what they were doing because they can't
like we will get these children addicted
to trans fats did you ever see the movie
the founder
i perused it okay
you know what he says at the end no
you don't get elvis has left the
building no you still don't get it
that's what he says that's what michael
says you don't get it
it's the name
mcdonald's
it's
america he's irish he's right
it's america you you could and by the
way burger king did have parties space
balls pizza the hut they did have
parties they had the the kid they they
they had to change their parties yeah
yeah i know they did yeah my point is is
this is a this is a family
staple mcdonald's it is a cornerstone of
the americans the reason it's a family
staple is that they made a clown their
spokesperson and offered toys to
children who came in they had a strategy
their strategy was to get the children
to beg the parents to bring them there
so they can get their toys play in the
playpen and see the clown right okay the
whole business model is built around
smoke and mirrors
it's no one would if i went to a place
that was non-descript and didn't have
the aesthetic that mcdonald's had
geared toward children and i bit into
their burger i wouldn't be like i'm
going to be coming back here for years
this is a staple of of americana right
here this is delicious this is amongst
some of the best most addictive
cheeseburgers i would eat it and i would
forget about it but what happened was
and i'm sure they didn't go nuts until
they brought ronald in
i wonder when they really hit their
stride it was when they had children
begging parents to bring them to the
place okay and i bet you burger king
came after and i bet you they started
with the king
to compete with the clown and then
wendy's you know dave had to just march
his daughter out there and sacrifice his
own daughter but
but everybody needed a mascot after that
like you know what i mean like pizza hut
doesn't need a mascot it's pizza you
know what you're getting or come in get
some pizza okay
what's your point okay my point is that
what are you doing
i'm sorry i also have a life outside of
this podcast that i need to tend to
sometimes but you can say hold on a
second and we can stop down i know i'm
trying to keep us rolling
all right hold on a second
yeah i don't know dude i you know and
you know i got mcdonald's more as a kid
than i got pizza hut and pizza always
was more exciting
to realize that we were going to go get
even when i got older i was like oh
pizza i've been there in so long it's a
more special trip to me than mcdonald's
mcdonald's is just it's just in your
face you can't get enough already you
can't fault a company for for for for
for servicing your every need
you can't joe they serve burgers chicken
and fries you can't follow the company
for concierge service do you understand
that do you understand
mcdonald's is the luxury suv of fast
food they are there for you
they are there for you at every turn
whatever you need whatever your quarter
turn whatever your your most minor or
most extreme convenience is they are
there to service it do you understand
that you think they're the luxury suv
you take it for granted you take it for
granted you take it for granted okay you
know who else we take for granted in
this life are parents why because they
give unconditional love they provide
they'll always be there so hey i don't
need to see my folks today i'll go futz
off with the boys for a few hours cause
that's more unique that's more rare my
buddy pizza hut i don't see him all the
time you know why because your buddy
pizza doesn't give a [ __ ] about you
mcdonald's loves you they're there for
you do you understand that do you really
understand that because i don't think
that you do can you back that up with
what
anything with what delicious convenient
inexpensive food for your entire life
for generations how is it how are they
any different than pizza hut
pizza first of all hell of a lot pricier
doesn't pizza no of a lot of prices
amazing deals he all over the front page
of that uh go together show me pizza go
to deals go to deals yeah right there
big dinner box two medium pizzas five
breakfasts and your chocolate price
i want a price on it hold on give me a
price on it
give me a price how many people are you
feeding there it doesn't matter i want a
price on it i guarantee you you're
feeding
maybe six to eight people
look at this you got a call to get this
is what i'm talking about you can order
right from the right from the website
okay
the page is baking the page is bacon
look at this that's cute i mean we're
already mcdonald's is crushing you right
now
i could make a random guess
on what the price i'm sorry i don't
think mcdonald's throws 24.99
24.99 to feed your entire family
i got news for you that's about a two
maybe three-person meal see two pizzas
breadsticks wings and pasta i don't know
how big you do three babies
for you i got news for you i don't know
the last time you had a medium from a
pizza hut but i've had it recently i had
a large recently it is not a big pie
that's not even the regular that's not
even the regular medium to you that's a
great medium pizza from pizza recently
i've had a large pizza pizza
i stopped at three pizzas on my
croissant trip
guess what guess what when i get pizza
by myself which i can't anymore because
there's no pizza out of new york but
when i was eating pizza by the way
lactose what do you mean i'm saying i
haven't had oh i ate pizza i i love
pizza
you love pizza hut so much
that you you
thumb your nose at your lactose
intolerance yes and you you eat the
pizza i don't have lactose intolerance i
have a lactose allergy it's a different
thing
tomato tomato barley no it's not it is
it's not it is now i brought you brought
it up you have i'm glad you brought up
tomatoes you have i bet you brought up
tomatoes
despite your lactose what is it called
allergy you have a lactose algae and
you're like i don't i know i'm going to
pay for this i just know i'm going to
pay this no but i don't know
that's not how it works that's not how
it works nobody out pizza's the hot bro
first of all i just did a cheeseburger
and it set off my lactose allergy that's
one little american square slice of
cheese you're eating a large pie
your allergies first of all pizza
doesn't set off my lactose allergy
certain lactose products do well i i
wonder so that's why it's not intolerant
is that a check in the positives for
pizza in the box i could give a [ __ ] it
tastes good to me i don't know you won't
give a [ __ ] because it's not but i want
to point something out to you that is
your that is a reshaped medium pizza
from pizza when i get pizza by myself
which is very rare i get a large in the
one sitting for dinner i eat almost more
than half of it it is not a big thing to
eat what are you arguing the fact that
two pies wings are pasta bowl and
breakfast no it's not a good family meal
with 20 pounds
you get wings or pups get your finger
out of my face you get wings what's your
family meal you get what's your favorite
it's a thing you can only get in atlanta
because it's for the atlanta falcons
okay and they serve it at football
seasons two quarter pounders with cheese
a 20-piece mcnugget two large fries two
large cokes twenty dollars it's the deal
of a lifetime it's only available in
atlanta for falcons players they do it
different in different cities by the way
that
is not getting you as much food as that
is
that's true that's that's not it's not
buddy by the way it's wings or pasta i'm
gonna put that out which gives you an
idea of the level of their pasta that
they're saying you can have hot wings
i need you to come to the table with a
better argument come on man i need you
to stop talking about mcdonald's like
it's mcdonald's
shakes ice cream pies cheeseburgers are
you talking about
the big mac the ultimate version of the
california burger the best burger on
planet earth the big mac nuggets chicken
sandwiches by the way this is fast food
by the way mediocre and by the way this
is what i love about mcdonald's they
have chicken sandwiches that are actual
chicken and then they have chicken
sandwiches that are the hodgepodge of
chicken nuggets because they know both
are awesome and they're like whatever
you want you want the real thing we got
it you want a fake thing we got that too
buddy we're here for you why do you
think you love it you love it because
it's good
you think that you love it because it
tastes good and put his salad dressing
in every mcdonald's in the world paul
newman so what about it the leading
celebrity salad dressing is included
with mcdonald's
[Laughter]
you don't eat mcdonald's because it
tastes good dude you you're
shout you're you eat mcdonald's at a
young age when you had no friends that
clown looked you in the eyes of the
television and said joe i'll be your
friend so you people at mcdonald's if
grimace is here he'll be your friend so
you think you were you murdered with the
clown you went in there you got a toy
and you got to feel good about yourself
for once at a time i think and now you
associate that with good feelings the
burger the cheeseburger you just using
and the
chicken that you just ate is not you
don't keep going back there for quality
you called it luxury before i said they
are the luxury suvs of fast food that's
the main thing i've ever heard about but
you don't even know what it means it's
not luxury but you don't get it
why luxury suv because a luxury suv has
what's called concierge service inside
of it when you sit in a luxury suv it
has all these amenities inside the car
to make your drive convenient mcdonald's
is here to make your life convenient
at any time
place is the same exactly
how is burger king not trying to do the
same thing you said mcdonald's is a
luxury suv of fast food nobody is as
consistent and delivers in the way in
the fast food department to every aspect
of your daily needs like mcdonald's what
what proof do you have to back that up
how is mcdonald's different
there charles jr sonic burger king
what a burger fat burger dog in and out
how is it don't get me started how is it
different you tell me mcdonald's is
known for white glove service
buddy you go into a mcdonald's in
alabama you go into a mcdonald's in
scotland you go into a mcdonald's in
texas you go to mcdonald's in
pennsylvania you go new mcdonald's in
france it is going to look the same it
is going to taste somewhat the same
regionally it will change a bit because
of flavors in different countries but it
is going to immediately walk to back it
is going to taste the same as is every
single chain fast food spot that's wrong
who doesn't look and taste the same
who's not dealing
with i used to live next to a
whataburger when i lived in texas i
every time i went to that i sat i'm not
exaggerating at times 55 minutes waiting
for my food that's how long it took it's
not the same it's not the same there's
an ingredient because you wanted to eat
a burger one time and waited for the
food i've gone to kfc my order's been
completely wrong i've gone to burger
king they've forgotten stuff you go to
mcdonald's it is
you never get a big mac and go they
forgot the pickles it doesn't happen
have you ever seen someone scream at you
from resting on their back
have you ever seen that he's shouting
half of me in half at the ceiling and
he's fine with it i just i'm all amped
up the pig just walked in
and there he is
he's he's it was his birthday so he
chose mcdonald's again for the million
times and he's feverishly arguing that
mcdonald's is a luxury item
yeah yeah yeah here you go here you go
with the [ __ ] pig like derosa he
didn't choose mcdonald's mcdonald's
that's what i said yeah that's what i
said i said he's not eating it for the
taste he's eating it because as a child
he looked at a tv and the clown was like
i'll be your only friend yeah mcdonald's
mcdonald's scouts from phoenixville
pennsylvania where this piece of [ __ ] is
from
that's the only [ __ ] thing you're
worth
this is what you deserve on your
birthday is
some type of bacterial infection you're
interested from the chicken nuggets you
ain't you piece of [ __ ] yeah that's my
birthday buddy look at dex man look at
this trash look he's got a gold bracelet
fitbit
[Laughter]
i'm going to take some of jazz's pain
killer she just got from her surgery and
get [ __ ] lights out
all right look let's go to the phones we
got to start we got to start wrapping it
up let's go to the phones
is pizza hut still a thing
boom
should have been papa john's pizza is
not the top pizza chain in my book but
glad joe derosa comedy gets the win
uh mcdonald's is heroin
it is it is it gives you a warm feeling
in your chest while you stuff your face
however the nausea a few hours later is
rough i bet at any given moment at any
given moment in any mcdonald's around
the world 10 of the people sitting in it
are going to die soon this girl this
girl summed it all up and i
scroll up a couple pimp
stop
she
she just summed it all up mcdonald's
pizza hut doesn't have mascots you think
that's a plus it's huge a man you want a
mask you need a mascot at your
restaurant
you need it i just said you keep proving
me right you don't understand that you
subconsciously love it because you think
they're your friends
they were your only friends growing up
and now you're gonna go back there all
the time because it's the only thing
that makes you feel like a regular boy
mcdonald's cheaper faster overall tastes
better oh my god you're going to get
you're going to get creamed
you want to call mcdonald's what it is
call it what it is it's cheap food it's
fast food it's it has toys for kids it
lures them in if it gives them a [ __ ]
ball pit but let's not let's not make
believe mcdonald's is good food
pizza hut is at least decent food i'm
going to buy if i'm going to buy food
that isn't good for my health it might
as well taste good t mcdonald's
mcdonald's doesn't taste good it tastes
like mcdonald's it's not good or bad it
just is what it is god you're so you're
brainwashed on the taste you're
brainwashed they've proven that those
fries are addictive for some reason so
they put msg into something whatever
they do you all stop trying to pump
joe's numbers up
[Music]
the answer could change
if red plastic soda cups are involved
until then the clown takes it
uh maybe if they change it up generosity
probably took pizza to throw us off now
but i i we might that might have
actually been fun like we did weed booze
rematch i like to go to mcdonald's but i
never go to pizza hut
i love mcdonald's unless pizzas start
making pizza mcmuffins you guys know why
you're gonna get creamed pizza would
kill you
bottom line is a pizza would slaughter a
cheeseburger i think in a battle and
we're talking about a pizza place versus
burger place what kind of serial killer
would choose pizza hut over mcdonald's
mcdonald's is sad but pizza understood
jesus christ
that's the litter
at least pizza hut uh you still get
pizza and not fake pink sludge like
chicken mcnuggets oh god what we've all
seen the videos i watched an instagram
video
shut up
shut up who tweeted that boar's call off
no but it's like they appeal ago
you do
yeah i don't care that's right it's like
somebody that goes you should quit
smoking it's bad for you oh really in
one second thank you in one sentence he
calls mcdonald's a luxury suv and one
minute later he goes hey no it's pink
sludge and i don't care i'm saying they
offer you concierge service and the fact
that they are there to service you
donald's over the concierge service it's
the stupidest [ __ ] i want
i've ever heard in my life they don't
know if a concierge i want you to school
i want you to
[Music]
[Music]
right now
i want you to pull your car over and go
into the first mcdonald's you see the
first one the second you walk in there
take a photo of the person at the
register and to heat it at us and put in
a cup tell me and tell me if these
people look like they tell me
white clothes
tell me and tell me how fast you get
that food and how it looks exactly like
a picture
it's under a heat lamp here is a
sentence nobody has ever uttered ever
ever ever that's here
they didn't remember the cheese on my
quarter pounder my nuggets were
undercooked they forgot the ketchup they
never [ __ ] up do you understand are you
insane they [ __ ] you at the drive-thru
everyone knows that mcdonald's never
[ __ ] up i i literally went to a
mcdonald's drive-through and and i
literally had to report them because
they were so terrible
yes oh you [ __ ] no no no no no no i
didn't report them we talked about it no
no we talked about it on hey babe and
the owner got wind of it and
apologized also forgot our fries today
yeah we had to reorder it
[Laughter]
they forgot they [ __ ] them on this
order your birthday order listen you
mcdonald's little mcdonald's [ __ ]
stop defending them so why do you fight
tooth and nail for this company
mcdonald's don't they're not gonna pay
your rent all right all right we got the
winner here
mcdonald's is sad but pizza is
depressing follow underscore louie
l-o-u-i-e
and then the number two let's here it is
here it is you got plugs same now
because this is the end
salvocanocomedy.com right now all my
full dates are on sale we added second
shows in toronto hershey pennsylvania
and atlanta we're doing about a dozen
two dozen cities starting in october
everything on sale right now merch is
all there and uh support the pod guys
tell a friend subscribe here to the no
press channel follow us on on on spotify
and rate us on itunes take a minute out
of your day joe derosa info for all my
tour dates and tickets
uh i'm not sure where this is dropping
on the schedule but go there there's
tons of shows and everything come out to
see me please
joeyrosesmyc.com for all joey rose's
info come see us at the spot tuesday
through sunday opening at 12 p.m every
day listen if all you got to know as i
guarantee you in the next month or two
joe derosa will be with soul joel on a
field somewhere in pennsylvania so just
go to
souljalls.com and i guarantee you'll
find derosa's dates or what are you
doing
[Laughter]
or or or pop into any mcdonald's and
wait a little bit
all right here we go here we go here we
go get ready
we got 16 17 000 votes
[Laughter]
71.8 percent in favor of mcdonald's to
pizza it's 28.2
this has been a great birthday i i still
love you buddy i love you too taste buds
they coming to the mic talking about the
food they hate talking about the food
they like two fools gonna fight but only
one food can be right taste